only from the i-team new video and crime
scene photos in the murder case of
leslie palacio
eric rangel ibarra is charged with the
murder and right now he remains on the
loose
now his father jose rangala is charged
with helping his son try to cover it up
afterwards and now evidence from that
case
showing how prosecutors say it all
happened a warning
some of the footage is disturbing the
i-team's david charns has more
prosecutors say video from the morning
of august 29 shows 25 year old eric
rangel labara helping 22 year old leslie
palacio
seen here alive get out of his truck and
into the house
an hour later in video we blurred due to
its graphic nature
the same camera catches rangelabara and
another man who prosecutors believe is
his father
46 year old jose rangel dragging a
lifeless body from the home
and into that same truck minutes after
the truck drives off
leaving rangel hosing off the walkway
police say rengella barra killed palacio
and then left the country with his
father these crime scene photos inside
the home showing a stripped bed
and blood spatter though investigators
say they have yet to determine whose
blood it is
investigators also taking photos of
gloves and cleaning supplies in the home
court documents showing rangel initially
told police that
eric told him palacio had died from an
overdose
he told police the first time he saw the
body was when eric dragged it down the
stairs of their home on a sheet
two weeks later palacio's body is found
off a road near the valley of fire
concealed behind the bush we need to
catch the main character
investigators arrested brangel near the
u.s mexico border last month
he told officers he had driven to mexico
with eric
and then they split up after that
palacio's family says
this is just the beginning we're not
going to stop until he
eric is finally caught a grand jury
charged jose rangel with destroying or
concealing evidence and accessory to
commit murder
eric rangelabarra is charged with the
murder and destroying evidence
he remains on the run the coroner has
yet to release palacio's cause of death
i'm david charns 8 news now